en el este de Ucrania es uno de los
principales objetivos de Rusia su
captura daríamos un nuevo punto de apoyo
en la región de doñez y una victoria
tras varios meses de reveses una meta
que los soldados ucranianos tienen muy
presente
necesitamos más armas es lo más
importante más tanques artillería
vehículos blindados tenemos experiencia
pero no herramientas para expulsar al
enemigo
la guerra es muy difícil perdimos a
mucha gente sabemos por lo que luchamos
cada guerra tiene su precio estamos
pagando el precio estamos luchando por
la libertad
del lado ruso el precio de este primer
año de ofensiva se siente también en
sebastopol se celebró una ceremonia en
memoria del personal de la marina rusa
fallecido en Ucrania siguiendo La
retórica del kremlin una pequeña
multitud honró a los que murieron bajo
la mano de un enemigo en decadencia
Dios quiere castigar a un hombre le
quita el sentido
Europa América todo el mundo civilizado
ha perdido esencialmente el sentido
común por lo que están haciendo los
pasos que están dándoles alejan de Dios
de la fe de la moral de los valores
humanos
el sábado el presidente Ucrania no voló
que su país puede poner fin a la
agresión rusa este año con la ayuda de
Alemania y del resto de sus aliados en
el terreno del ejército ucraniano
comunicó que los esfuerzos ofensivos
rusos siguen concentrándose por el
momento en el este y noreste industrial
de Ucrania